[Music]
good evening it's an honor to be here at
the governor's award and to speak about
David Lynch we met her we met at the
dinner parties her friend in New York
and the first thing David said to me was
you know you look like you could be
Ingrid Bergman's daughter which caused
one of our friends to say you idiot she
is Ingrid Bergman's daughter our dinner
conversation continued and I was sitting
next to David and he told me he was
casting for his new film blue velvet he
he was desperate to cast Helen Mirren in
the role of Dorothy valance to tortured
night like nightclub singer but Helen
had declined the part because it was a
little bit controversial
so dinner Donna went home and the next
day the door rang the doorbell rang and
a messenger delivered me the script of
blue velvet with a note from David it
says on second thought since Helen
wouldn't do the film would you consider
it so I read the script I also watched a
few of David's film he raised her head
and elephant men
there were so much anxiety surrealism
mystery and humor dark humor in the
first film and so much warm compassion
and tenderness in the second film I
thought wow this director can capture a
vast array of human emotion and he has
an incredible original style but before
accepting the role I because I knew it
was a little controversial I asked if I
could meet Col McClellan who had been
cast as the lead so Kyle and I got in a
hotel room and we got into our hotel
room to improvise the scenes that we
were going to play and we did them in
front of David so we can see if we all
were in the same wavelength and if we
can all get together and work well
together and this is when I learned that
we David his words are not nearly as
important as his reactions he's a
director whose face convey exactly what
he's thinking I learned that when you
are in one of his films and learned it
when you are in one of these films you
have to let his quiet guide you simply
put you can tell what he likes and
doesn't like but just looking at him
which is why right now the emotions
which David cannot hide are dug out of
us actors and we serve them for his film
and here is the core of his genius and
his brilliance for he and his film are
always full of emotions but emotions as
we all know very well are not always
rational linear clear so don't look for
straight linear simple narrative in
David's film he dwells much deeper than
that he dwells in a realm of emotion
that elude simple explanation definitive
answer
rationality he is attracted to
story and he tries to capture it for his
film the mysteries of our emotions of
our feelings of our passions of our life
david muse is mystery